last week we discussed the kinematics of
motion how one describes the motion of
an object by specifying its position
velocity and acceleration as a function
of time this week we will continue by
discussing the dynamics of motion how
the application of forces on an object
changes the geometry or trajectory of
its motion we will see that the applied
forces and the change in trajectory are
related through Newton's laws of motion
we will begin by reviewing Newton's
three laws of motion
these were a landmark achievement in
scientific thought most people who
haven't studied physics tend to
intuitively think in terms of the
ancient mechanics of Aristotle in which
an applied force is required to maintain
a body in uniform motion superficially
this seems to agree with our everyday
experience but only because friction
plays such an important role in our
everyday life one of Newton's great
insights was that applied forces caused
changes in an object's motion rather
than being necessary to maintain uniform
motion Newton's laws were the end result
of a great deal of careful definition
observation and reasoning by many
scientists up to an including Newton it
is a fascinating and compelling chapter
in the history of science but we will
not discuss that history in this course
instead we will simply state Newton's
three laws of motion as assumed
postulates or axioms and discuss their
meaning and application finally we will
consider several specific examples of
physical forces such as gravity contact
forces exerted by a solid surface like
the so called normal force which acts
perpendicular or normal to the surface
and friction which acts parallel to the
surface pulling forces like tension in a
rope or chain and the force exerted by a
stretched or compressed spring described
by Hookes law taken as a whole this week
will show us how to connect the two
sides of Newton's second law of motion F
equals MA the dynamics or application of
forces on the left hand side and its
relation to the kinematics the
change in geometry of the objects motion
or trajectory on the right hand side